oh hi there I'm coming about your the  hence pick baby crib no there's no  problem with it I think the biggest  issue that I'm having right now is that  the the crib has didn't come assembled  there's just an enormous amount of  hardware that's come with this unit and  I can be honest I'm having a real hard  time you know put this thing together  Swedish  well besides slow descent into  alcoholism I'm just really having  trouble finding all the screws and the  pieces that go with that I mean there's  got to be over 100,000 pieces that came  with it I'm just wondering if there's a  representative or or five that can come  by and make this happen for me and a  good day to you too  thank you  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]